siete pronti
io no questo video è il finale di b1
full flat della mappa che ho iniziato la
scorsa settimana non vedo l'ora di
vedere come gioca quell'uomo che al nome
che inizia con la p e finisce con loro
paolo vediamo di riuscire a finire
questa mappa maledetta buona visione
porto da juke e richiamo ma a questo
punto non è però finita lì si pensa come
la carica ma ho preso la battaglia e
mais voltaggio dici ok va bene visto che
c'erano e bisogna mette la batteria qua
credo mi raccomando collega almeno con
meno più col più sono grazie amico mio
veramente non so voi ringraziarti ora
gira e rigira quanto è lento perché la
barca bossi rassicura che sia ancora
tutto per cento ci guardano da mensa
caricando
ma quanto lungo allora ma non c'è
nessuno come demo toccarla non toccarla
tra eva e gira gira di vino dire in
fermare se ti fermi ripartire da zero
davvero si
mammamia guarda come mollato come
funziona bene e cosa facevi tu a parte
bloccare del centro e trovai staccala
vieni qua ciccio ha meno soldi meno e ci
sono 22 i ragazzi se no no e 2 no giorno
un'altra non so dove sia immagine cima
ci vado a prenderla porca vacca ragazzi
ha trovato l'altra batteria bravissimo
almeno otto che del climbing però l'ho
trovata io sull'aborto gioco ma non è
possibile
la carico io e io faccio tutto io che da
solo faccio più faccio più prima
italiana a ho trovato le duracell per
far funzionare l'ascensore sei ore di
batterie ma mi sa manco l'iphone dura
così tanto la famiglia del se riesco a
mettere dentro
zac anziana ma uno che si deve
sacrificare va benissimo
no no no no no no in realtà se in realtà
in realtà si esatto c'è nel senso no
allora se non aveva fuori di fare i
pirla si scaricano tutte le pile
ma perché non ci prendi e va beh non
importa insomma quest'anno davanti solo
io faccio io
ciao come la batteria si scaricavano una
certa quindi ho preferito continuare
ragazzino paurissima
ho avuto veramente paura ci sia io sono
davanti continui la sinistra siamo
arrivati al cospetto del castello sei
ore per arrivare al castello regalo ma
che bel castello marcondiro di non
nerino sento degli spiriti sentite gli
spiriti
no perché se con cui troppo lento che li
senso tempera i rumori che si sentono
nella buca avere di segreti di harry
potter facciamo kong kong a un trenino
questa fetta potete buttarvi giù
internet è ok con tutto rotto non è
esattamente kong a questi problemi ma
ripaga per babbuini andiamo al gran
serve qua sono secondo me questi fini
casi è successo
servono per prendilo prendere il filobus
servono per collegare ti ricordi ci
siano altre mappe che ma prendi il filo
blu ma e se non sappiamo dove metterlo
come il filo più lui ma prendi loro equa
so bisogna collegarli di sopra andiamo
dispone non sapevo cosa serviva magari
andare altra parte bene andiamo su di
amicizia vai ciccio lai ciccio bravo cc
o bravo ciccio bravo ciccio non così
ciccio pace
no no faccio io anche questo ragazzo
meno male che ci sono io che faccio le
lettrici di fase bravissimo sono
bravissimi
qua c'è un cose che dobbiamo avvicinare
a sé un magnete semplicemente questo può
essere per attivare il magnetismo di
qualcosa e attacca questa mamma mia
vabbè si apre si aprono delle cose
aspetta è che che serve non so se è
aperta solo la finestra ho capito che il
caso studiata in un modo incredibile già
provato dalle arti aggrappati e
dondolati a destra a questo punto
malatesta tipo c'è un balconcino quando
esce però aggrapparti in serata
dall'arte sulla destra ha preso a destra
cioè la fai aia porca vacca che male
apre che vada lei mi sono fatto
malissimo amici tifosi life in angola
via
inutili a fa na cosa mamma mia ami ha
inciso la roccia fatta c'è lotta sono
bravissimo per l'elettricità voglio
vedere questa cosa togli la peugeot
madonna che volta hai fatto casini ma ho
staccato che è stato attaccato
all'attacco l'altro ma tutto sta caduti
giù ma ragazzo poteva aprire la porta da
prima quindi avrebbe anche bisogno di
fare sta cosa fare per farlo grazie
non so dove sia pietro ma vabbè arrivano
sollevando amici il viaggiatore
achievement buttavo raga mi sa che siamo
arrivati alla fine ci sono delle altre
batterie da mettere figurati procedere
le situazioni ci butta in mezzo non si
può fare una frase le viti la regione
sta roba qua per ragazzi col solo questo
l'acqua il cartello da ragazzi renato
cioè la persona acqua dimostrare la sua
grande stein qualcosa e frankenstein
vediamo ma come marevivo sto vedendo è
pensa di sì pilastro pò qua ma con cavo
ragazzi ma carroccio già il russo
vogliamo staccarlo tosto prima ma non
penso che ci arrivino quanto il corso
delle cose soprattutto quello di coro e
quello di prima non è così lungo porca
vacca nuovo vika visto citando adesso va
tutto sto casino per quella che secondo
me come semplicemente un altro metodo
per arrivare di sopra no palco il tubo
roso trovato dove è vissuto per doveva
prenderlo non ho questo tipo lo riporta
quali foto col guscio di portato
praticamente poi facciamo salire
metti il cavo e taylor piglio valore
aspettava dal ha figlio pietro stai
fermo siamo qua perché non perché le
braccia rimbambite aspettami si sono
addormentati abbracciano guarda guarda
mi ok adesso ci sono già stati ok vaiti
ratan tata
l'ascensore torna su ragazzi perché mi
sembra troppo semplice cui pende di se
lasciasse di ragazzo mio se non ti muovi
io vengo a casa tua e ti squarto porco
del demonio schifoso poiché il gioco con
questi e porco schifo guarda tutto mito
rifà il qualcosa tenendo lo stop è il
motivo del perché e lo sto tenendo
ragazzi poi così impossibile
io lo so lega lo stavo tenendo
tranquillamente così in cagliari c'è un
bravo le chiamo più allegato pietro 9
legato inserisce nella parte inserisci
dall'altra eason dentro il country ma
secondo lega allora la fa inserito quasi
cirio per ciccio by ciccio di rosso
frankestein vive vive a sta muovendo
no io non so manco tira su si sta
verificando lo zio vivi vivi archiavata
amici mi ha catapultato nel nulla era
finito via finito si ricava che era
bellissimo che ha catapultato nel
lievito complicati che figo è visto che
siano per creare frankenstein a e ho
preso da è che siamo a k quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa
sinceramente mi piace passato anche
delle canaline ragazzine d'iscrizione è
noi ci rivediamo come sempre ad un
prossimo video mamma che faticare
gabella ragazzi
[Musica]